this of Justice the conviction and the
sentence imposed in respective must be
set aside and the conviction substituted
with a conviction of the correct effects
of course the accused has now served a
portion of the sentence imposed upon him
in respect to the lesser offense of
culpable homicide but the issue of what
would be an appropriate sentence was not
debated before this court quite properly
particularly in the light of the
constitutional court's judgments in Alba
Lisa and Beaumont's as the matter must
be sent back to the trial court for
sentence to be imposed afresh in doing
so obviously whatever punishment has
already been served by the accused in
respect to the incorrect conviction of
culpable homicide will be taken into
account before closing it is necessary
to make a final comment the trial was
conducted in the glare of international
attention and the focus of television
cameras which must have added to the
inherently heavy rigors that are brought
to bear upon trial courts in conducting
lengthy and complicated trials the trial
judge conducted the hearing with a
degree of dignity and patience that is
accredited to the judiciary of this
country the fact that this Court has
determined that certain mistakes were
made should not be seen as an adverse
comment upon her competence and ability
the fact is that different judges reach
different conclusions and in the light
of an appeal structure those of the
appellate court prevail but the fact
that the appeal has succeeded is not to
be regarded as a slight upon the trial
judge who's to be congratulated for the
men and which he conducted the
proceedings
I conclude with the following order
being to be made one the first two
questions of law reserved are answered
in favor of the Director of Public
Prosecutions
to the accused conviction and sentence
on count one are set aside and replaced
with the following guilty of murder with
the accused having had criminal intent
in the form of dollars eventually three
the methods referred back to the trial
court to consider an appropriate
sentence afresh in the light of the
comments in this judgment
well there you have at least Supreme
Appeal Court the judge there judge leach
has found Oscar Pistorius guilty of
murder he said he ought to have been
convicted not of culpable homicide but
murdered here they're now referring for
sentencing